i
bienvenidos a la entrevista
finalmente el telescopio james webb fue
lanzado al espacio tras una espera de 30
años y después de superar innumerables
traspiés que elevó su presupuesto a 10
mil millones de dólares este instrumento
de observación con una grandeza y
potencia jamás construida explorará los
orígenes del universo y de los
exoplanetas parecidos a la tierra el
telescopio james webb que seguirá los
pasos del mítico hubble fue diseñado en
colaboración con la agencia espacial
europea y canadiense y se fabricó en
eeuu
sus creadores señalan que es tan potente
que es capaz de ver un abejorro a 380
mil kilómetros de distancia es decir la
distancia entre la tierra y la luna a
continuación la entrevista realizada a
pierre ferriz uno de los científicos a
cargo del proyecto del telescopio en la
agencia espacial europea
se va a lanzar el telescopio webb para
reemplazar por así decirlo al telescopio
hubble que traerá de nuevo va a traer
muchas cosas en realidad no se lanza
para reemplazar al telescopio espacial
hubble sino que es algo así como la
próxima generación y web porque lo
llamamos web es en realidad un
telescopio mucho más grande que el
telescopio también tiene la 'roja' así
que lo que realmente va a mirar es el
universo de una manera diferente
el hecho de que sea más grande le
permitirá observar objetos que están
mucho más lejos mucho más débiles por lo
que descubrirá cosas que el joven no
puede alcanzar cómo funciona esta
edición impresa
esta visión infrarroja consiste en mirar
esas luces que son de ese color que está
más allá del ojo que nuestros ojos
pueden ver el infrarrojo por lo tanto el
interés es científico ya que el web fue
construido para responder a preguntas
científicas y en particular el limpiar
rojo es finalmente el color predilecto
para observar las primeras galaxias de
nuestro lugar que aparecieron hace más
de 13.000 millones de años y mucho más
cercano a nosotros por ejemplo también
es el color predilecto para estudiar la
atmósfera de los famosos exoplanetas
esos planetas que giran alrededor de
metas estrellas así en el infrarrojo
podemos buscar rastros de agua vapor de
agua por ejemplo lo cual es muy muy
interesante
a menudo se dice que revolucionó nuestro
conocimiento del cosmos sobre la
formación de las galaxias
qué más puede aportar concretamente el
web qué preguntas concretas le gustaría
que se respondiera
isabel realmente ha revolucionado muchas
áreas de la astrofísica y el comienzo de
la concepción del web
tuvo lugar justo después del lanzamiento
los científicos pensaron que preguntas
podía responder al jaber que preguntas
quedarían sin respuesta y por lo tanto
en que debería ir para eso y eso llevó
al web entonces las palabras realmente
importantes son un telescopio grande
cuando decimos grande significa que
recogen luz podemos ir más lejos podemos
ver objetos más débiles y ahí es donde
él sabe en un momento dado llega a sus
límites y él web van más allá de estos
límites para ver realmente las primeras
galaxias y para la visión infrarroja el
campo predilecto para observar estas
primeras galaxias es una vez más el
infrarrojo y cuando hablamos de la
atmósfera de los planetas extrasolares
no sabemos por qué de hecho todas esas
moléculas que nos interesan ya mencioné
el agua pero también están el monóxido
de carbono el dióxido de carbono el
metano todas estas moléculas tienen
firmas en el infrarrojo por lo tanto es
increíble tener una visión infrarroja
solo para ser más realista no podremos
tomar fotos de un exoplaneta en otro
sistema no veremos este tipo de
la mayoría de los exoplanetas no pueden
separarse de sus estrellas es decir si
están demasiado cerca unos de otros no
pueden distinguirse por lo que los
estudiaremos indirectamente pero puedo
decir que podremos ver planetas aunque
tendrán que estar muy muy lejos de su
estrella tienen que ser grandes y no
veremos detalles del planeta será sólo
un punto pero algunos exoplanetas pueden
detectarse independientemente de su
estrella así que si podemos verlo
sabemos ya qué misión será la primera
que se le pide al telescopio
no sé cuál es la primera misión de la
organización del primer año aún no está
completa pero lo que sí sabemos es que
ya hemos seleccionado todas las
observaciones que realizará el web en su
primer año así que sabemos que tenemos
un programa bastante excepcional su
variado y el que los científicos
europeos lo están haciendo muy bien y
tienen una gran participación
usted es el responsable científico en la
parte europea de la misión en las
observaciones que realizará durante el
primer año de funcionamiento del james
webb de cuales pidió tener
si participó en las observaciones y en
particular en las observaciones
vinculadas a la formación y a la
evolución de las galaxias es entonces
una mirada desde fui muy lejos en
astronomía mirar desde una gran
distancia significa retroceder en el
tiempo porque la luz tarda en llegar
hasta nosotros así que estoy bastante
interesado personalmente en mi propia
investigación sobre la formación y la
evolución de las galaxias los
exoplanetas me fascinan mucho pero no es
muy especial
qué preguntas quiere que se respondan
sobre la internación de las galaxias
no sabemos cómo son estas primeras
galaxias aún no hemos podido observar
las por lo que el web va a suponer un
gran avance en este campo
y el ejemplo que os pongo siempre es que
la infancia de un ser humano es
importante para aquello en lo que se
convertirá después por tanto comprender
cómo se forman las galaxias su primera
infancia es muy importante para entender
el universo que nos rodea ahora el
universo actual así que son cuestiones
importantes por ese lado
ya vimos cuando se lanzó el telescopio
hubble que no funcionó de inmediato que
tuvo bastantes problemas y si ocurre lo
mismo con james webb sabemos que no
podremos repararlo esta vez las
posibilidades de que todo salga bien son
de alrededor del 90% no hay un pequeño
riesgo ahí
nunca se puede poner un porcentaje a las
posibilidades de que haya un problema
pero hay dos cosas el momento crítico va
a ser el lanzamiento y el jueves está
realmente en buenas manos porque haría
de 5 es el ganador más segundo el mundo
es difícil elegir algo mejor
luego hay toda una etapa para web que
será su despliegue porque es tan grande
que se lanza completamente entregado así
que eso también será crítico durante las
tres primeras semanas de vida del web en
el espacio pero en realidad lo que
hicimos fue probar todo lo posible antes
de lanzarlo si había algún problema
queríamos detectarlo antes de estar
tarde así que realmente hicimos grandes
esfuerzos la nasa hizo grandes esfuerzos
para asegurarse de que todo marcharía
solo para hacernos una idea de lo
difícil que es la tarea este espejo está
plegado permite ver a qué desplegar la
alineación de los paneles debe ser de
qué medida la perfección debe ser micro
y ahí hicimos trampa porque por ejemplo
el espejo del web que está compuesto por
18 piezas tendrán que funcionar tú estás
solo espejo
y en el caso del web se alinearán una
vez en el espacio porque el web funciona
a temperaturas muy bajas ya es casi
imposible asegurarnos de que todo esté
bien ajustado inmediatamente
por lo que tenemos los medios para
alinear esto así que el miedo que
tenemos no ocurrirá con el web y qué
precisión buscan en términos de cifras
hablamos de micrómetros así que se trata
de una óptica de precisión lo estamos
entrando en los nanómetros la
milmillonésima parte de un kilómetro es
el micrómetro mío
el james webb va a estar a 1500
kilómetros de la tierra un punto de
lagrange puede explicarnos primero qué
es este punto y también por qué tan
lejos
este punto de lagrange es popular para
las divisiones astrofísicas y eso
explicará por qué enviamos al telescopio
webb pero primero hablaremos de este
punto es un punto matemático son cinco
del sistema sol tierra en este punto es
interesante porque es de equilibrio y
cuando ponemos un satélite en órbita
alrededor del punto de lagrange cuando
hablamos exactamente de la punto de
lagrange este satélite para mantener su
órbita tiene que hacer menos esfuerzo
así que menos esfuerzo para el satélite
significa utilizar menos combustible
significa que vivirá mal tiempo y será
utilizable durante maletín esa es la
primera razón la segunda es que no es
una órbita alrededor de la tierra el web
no va a girar alrededor de la tierra va
a girar alrededor del sol con la tierra
y estas condiciones de órbita van a
permitir esconder web todo el tiempo
detrás ya sufría antes como para sol que
es del tamaño de una cancha de tenis y
dejarlo aún preciso así que las
condiciones para la observación en
particular para un telescopio infrarrojo
en este punto a la grande son ideales y
no es primero
por ejemplo tres satélites de la esa el
telescopio planck y herschel que estaban
allí pero que
en este momento sigan en funcionamiento
está el satélite galia de la agencia
espacial europea que está allá y es muy
popular
no sólo ha evolucionado nuestro
conocimiento de la astrofísica sino que
también ha popularizado las fotos del
joven entre el pueblo en general así que
cómo serán las imágenes del huevo ya que
no tomará imágenes en vivo
y
no tomara fotos en luz visible el huevo
realmente observara en el infrarrojo y
la buena noticia es que debido a su
tamaño podrá proporcionar una calidad de
imagen en el infrarrojo equivalente a la
que tiene el abl para luz visible
así que esperen imágenes de la misma
calidad no se preocupen el universo
también es muy hermoso han entrado
usted hablaba del número de científicos
de los resultados que proporcionaron al
james webb
casi parece que es una pequeña empresa
la que va al espacio
será una economía alrededor de esos
empleos directos e indirectos
podría hablarnos de eso
si de hecho no empieza cuando los
científicos empiezan a utilizarlo porque
hay que darse cuenta de que por ejemplo
cuando hable de las contribuciones de la
agencia espacial europea y de europa a
través de la agencia en web
el instrumento ni spect por ejemplo lo
hicimos construir por la industria
europea por lo que no sólo hay empleo
sino que también está el mantenimiento
de una experiencia de un saber hacer
eso en cuanto a la parte más tecnológica
al saber a hacer y luego por supuesto
para los científicos significa empleos
porque vivir una investigación es muy
importante porque es la investigación
fundamental para entender cómo es
nuestro universo
estas son preguntas que la humanidad
quiere responder y que necesitamos creo
que al final es muy útil para nosotros
no solo para los científicos sino
también para la sociedad
cuántas personas componen la comunidad
del viaje
es difícil dar un número pero por
ejemplo cuando se les pidió a los
científicos que hicieran propuestas de
investigación hubo más de mil propuestas
y pueden imaginar que cada propuesta
había sido concebida por varios
científicos así que estamos hablando de
varios miles de científicos
y durante los 20 años de desarrollo del
web estamos hablando de varios miles de
personas no necesariamente científicos
sino ingenieros técnicos administradores
así que hay una gran variedad de
personas que han contribuido a lo que es
el hueco
ya se ha dicho todo sobre el huevo
tamaño las medidas el precio el retraso
estamos a dos meses del lanzamiento
nos sentimos bien desde ya es
emocionante es muy emocionante porque es
un momento que todos hemos estado
esperando llevo 20 años trabajando en el
web así que también es especial así que
es un gran momento de emoción de
expectativa de orgullo porque también es
un gran orgullo ver lo mucho que este
telescopio webb es esperado por los
científicos lo mucho que el público en
general también está interesado en el
web y poder decir a mi manera aporte un
grano de arena algo que es excepcional y
que es casi únicos solemos hablar del
web como el telescopio de una generación
porque con telescopio así no sucede a
menudo
añadiré una última pregunta estoy en la
obligación de hacer las su forma de nave
imperial se hizo a propósito
y
las respuestas que la forma tiene una
razón de ser no es para parecer una nave
imperial sino que la razón por la cual
tu plataforma es simplemente porque el
web tiene que estar muy frío funciona a
menos de 130 grados así que está muy muy
frío
y por eso en el espacio lo ponemos en la
oscuridad solo le dejamos ver el espacio
profundo que es muy frío para esto
hicimos este parasol que tiene esta
especie de forma de diamante por
supuesto cuando se envía algo al espacio
no se hace más grande de lo necesario y
la mejor forma para mantener la
telescopio en la oscuridad todo el
tiempo era esta forma de diamante así
que lo siento por los fans de star wars
no eran para que se pareciera un crucero
imperial
gracias
hasta aquí la entrevista gracias por
sintonizarnos sigue con la programación
de france 24 en español
[Música]
y